quand tu es au milieu d'une histoire ce
n'est pas du tout l'histoire et seulement une
confusion un rugissement sombre une cécité
c'est seulement après que ça devient
quelque chose comme une histoire quand tu la
racontes à toi-même ou à quelqu'un d'
autre Jack  pouvez-vous simplement revenir sur
cette ligne étant presque si réelle oh bien je
suppose que s'il pouvait commencer par décrire
maman avec autant de détails que possible moi est-
ce que tu me veux oh je suis désolé voici une
église et voici le clocher elle  était
la plus amusante à laquelle je pouvais penser en tant qu'enfant,
elle était très chaleureuse, elle était à l'écran o plein
de vie, il était logique qu'elle soit vieille et les
secrets qu'elle aspirait plus ne sont jamais
partis entre Navas en défense et je
me souviens tout d'un coup mon  maman n'était
pas là et je me souviens que les adultes
pleuraient je suppose que j'ai en quelque sorte bloqué à quoi
bon tu sais que la famille était
un assez gros gâchis maman a dû penser
qu'est-ce que j'ai fait de mal qui a conduit à cela je
lui ai dit que je ne le ferais jamais  en discuter avec qui que ce
soit et je ne l'ai jamais fait, je pense que c'est notre
famille et  d chaque famille a une histoire
personne n'en a jamais parlé qu'est-ce que tu te
souviens que j'ai dit j'ai tout ce truc dont
nous avons plaisanté pendant environ quatre ans c'est en
fait vrai je pense qu'elle peut être en train de réaliser
ce que sa vie pourrait être je pense qu'elle a fait
un choix  vivre c'est une belle histoire
super belle histoire de misty Haven je suis
dans le rouge pas surprenant je ne me
marierai jamais à la place je me comporte mal en économisant mes
revenus que diriez-vous que ce
documentaire parle vraiment de euh c'est un
bon angle pour moi
je  raté ça